sí sí
[Música]
y esto tiene
sí
[Música]
y si lo sabía
no existe
[Música]
tu mente
porlamar
millones
[Música]
no
y simple
sí
si por los hechos
[Música]
sólido
sí
si nos unimos
lo siento
[Música]
muchas de las acciones
[Aplausos]
activismo musical revolución le ganó 68
merchán músico colombiano soy de gan
y estoy aquí para contarles a quien
depender en activista y defensor de los
derechos de los animales después de
tenerlo todo y estar viviendo mi sueño
hecho realidad
en inglaterra tocando con las grandes
figuras del rock británico
pero hoy aquí estoy y aquí es donde me
gusta
pero como liberalismo
pues yo fui carnívoro de crianza y las
personas al camino
a los 22 años con una visión entendí que
los animales son seres sintientes y que
merecen respeto y derecho a la vida ante
este organismo por muchos años y después
cuando me enteré de la monstruosa
realidad
que viven los animales en el mundo he
decidido entregar mi música mi vida
con los derechos de las manos
[Aplausos]
el mecanismo es una filosofía de vida es
una postura ética que rechaza que los
ungidos de todos los productos de origen
animal
existen tres principales razones
planteamientos o motivos los éticos que
son los que lo definen los ambientales y
las de salud
ahora bien vamos con las dos son
estéticas 150 millones de animales son
sacrificados para la carne
canán eso sin contar los animales
marinos los de laboratorios
hoy en día las máquinas procesadoras son
tan sofisticadas que puedo acabar con
miles de vidas
y 90
[Música]
la industria láctea ya sabemos que está
llena de sufrimiento esclavitud
o la mastitis de hormonas de
inseminación artificial de robo de bebés
los machos otros que llamamos ternera
y las mismas paradas clave tales como
sus manos
la idea de ser dos vacas
y gallinas felices eso es publicidad
mentirosa
[Música]
de tus frío de los huevos tiene gallinas
empecemos condiciones de vida en el
cerramiento nunca verá el sol
24 horas de luz artificial los
marchistas como lo ponen huevos para
máquinas trituradoras pueden terminar en
cualquier acera por aquí
y hay muchas otras formas de crueldad
animal las pieles la experimentación con
fines cosméticos y científicos los
signos los callos el toreo la casa de la
miel y la lana la seda las plumas
piensa en eso
con todas las olas y los ideales que es
ideal a los animales en la industria
cárnica para alimentarnos podríamos
acabar con el hambre
siempre he pensado que eso es un crimen
[Música]
a una de las razones ambientales
y que escuchen tiempos ambientalistas y
las personas que dicen ser amantes del
planeta
la ganadería
principal la principal emisora de gases
de efecto invernadero
más que todos los medios de transporte
es el sentimiento del mundo
responsable de contaminación de agua
pérdida de bosques nada más en
sudamérica el 71% de los bosques se han
perdido a causa de la industrial enero
[Música]
y razones de salud
está demostrado que una dieta basada en
plantas y estoy hablando en una dieta
bien informada es más saludable los
veganos tenemos menos presión
de los cáncer diabetes y los
enfermedades del corazón
sabemos que la proteína
esta buena eficiente y tal vez mejor que
la proteína animal por eso existen
elefantes colinas reno será un test para
los tremendos maestros los animales
todos alimentos entrantes
tenemos los veganos la posibilidad de
mente de vivir más las vidas y también
más hablamos
[Música]
no se les olvide una cosa también
la industria farmacéutica quiere que
nosotros estemos enfermos porque ellos
también se quieren llenar los bolsillos
de dinero para constantes
eso se llama
liberación animal y su contraparte en
inglés ánimo de berrinche
estudio sí no
[Música]
sin duda
yo
[Música]
a mí
un día más
más que eso
la tensión
vivimos con los años
no no
yo
[Música]
no
yo estoy yo
usa
ah
a más
de pista
por favor
[Música]
todo el mundo
tú irme
yo sí
[Música]
sí
es importante
para nada
[Música]
es importante para mí decir que el
mensaje siempre siempre lo entrega por
amor con humildad con respeto
que hablan mis canciones y sus corazones
para mí siempre ha sido muy triste ver
como el mundo camina indiferente ante la
monstruosidad de la industria cárnica
las imágenes de contar a los animales
son tan fuertes que bueno que llevas de
mostrarlas porque uno de los olvidos
limpiamente está lleno lleno de
información no debemos
es importante saber esto también ninguna
ninguna religión
va a venir a salvar a los animales de su
sufrimiento a ellos les interesa su
círculo de amor compasión del que tanto
hablan
a casa para los animales
y ese es mi frase favorita si los
animales tuvieran una religión el tiempo
yo seríamos los humanos
les voy a de unas palabras que los
puntos
pero donde millones de animales son
sacrificados y utilizados violentamente
y donde millones de personas mueren de
cáncer u obesidad y donde otros cientos
de millones mueren de hambre
es hora de decir lo más entonces este es
el mensaje legalismo por los animales
corcho sal a nuestro hermoso planeta
porque el veganismo es la forma más
amorosa
inteligente
tenemos que evolucionar y revolucionar
por eso tenemos que ser parte de la
nueva revolución la individual la
particular la más poderosa por eso estoy
aquí
[Música]
eso se llama dígalo bacano y su
contraparte
[Música]
mañana
para mí
el sol
[Música]
la vida
amor
[Música]
camino
[Aplausos]
o no
[Música]
no sé
sí
t
[Música]
este
y mucho
en el amor
pues
el sol
tu camino
como que se fijan
presión
muchas naciones
es vital
por favor escriban y tratemos de hacer
comunidad una oportunidad que ha sido
muchas vidas es un placer estar acá
tenemos que mejorar